projectory going up we have not turned
that your trajectory nor have we hit the
apex remember what that line is going to
do it's going to go up it's going to
reach a high point it's going to tip
it's going to go back down we're still
on the way up the mountain number of
infections that have been coming in 80%
still self resolved about 15 percent of
the people who test positive require
hospitalization and then there are
degrees of hospitalization right but the
total universe that requires
hospitalization is 15 percent the Wii
U's projection models we have cornell
while which is a great medical
institution that does projection models
we use McKenzie that does projection
models Department of Health does
projection models the projection models
are important because they are
projecting the possible trajectory and
projecting the possible need right so
we're planning for a need the projection
models do that the projection models are
just that they are models of projections
they're not necessarily definitive but
it's the only device that we have to
plan right follow the data follow the
data follow the data the actual
hospitalizations have moved at a higher
rate than the projected models than all
the projected models so that was
obviously concern because that higher
infection rate means faster higher
capacity on the hospitals and that's the
critical point for us is the number of
people go into hospitals right now what
we're looking at is about a hundred and
forty thousand cases coming into the
hospitals the hospital capacity is 53
thousand beds that's a problem we're
looking at about 40,000 ICU cases coming
into the hospitals we have about 3,000
ICU beds that's a challenge
what is an ICU bed for these purposes
basically a bed with a ventilator the
ventilator is the most critical piece of
equipment for an intensive care unit bed
because this is a respiratory illness
and people need more ventilation than
usual what do we want to do reduce the
number of cases coming into the
hospitals slow the number of cases
coming into the hospital that's what
doctor foul Chi's talking about on TV
every day flatten the curve flatten the
curve flat and curve slow the number of
people coming into hospitals so we can
deal with them in the hospitals and we
are working on that at the same time
increase your Hospital capacity right so
try to slow the number of cases coming
into the hospital meanwhile raise your
Hospital capacity we are working on both
simultaneously we have been from day one
reduce the number of cases coming in
flatten the curve slow the spread of the
infection we are doing everything we can
on that that's banning non-essential
workers that social distancing that's
closing restaurants closing gyms just
flatten the curve slow the infection
rate one issue we had was in New York
City where we had a higher level of
density than we wanted especially in the
New York City parks especially with
young people I've been as direct as I
can and as blunt as I can on young
people and the misinformation that they
have you can catch the corona virus you
may think you are a superhero
you're really not you can catch it and
you can transfer it which makes you
dangerous to the people who you love but
the New York City parks have been a
problem
I saw the problem myself firsthand
I spoke to me DeBlasio I spoke to speak
for Johnson we said come up with a plan
in 24 hours that everybody agreed with
they came up with a plan when I
menteng that plan I signed off on that
plan the plan is going to pilot closing
streets in New York City because we have
much less traffic in New York City we
have many fewer vehicles in New York
City open streets people want to walk
they want to go out and get some air you
want a less dense area so pilot closing
streets to cars opening streets to
pedestrians the will also enact
mandatory playground social density it's
probably a new concept no close contact
sports in a playground no basketball for
example you cannot do it we're asking
people to do that on a voluntary basis
if there is non-compliance with that we
will then make it mandatory and we will
actually close the playgrounds we don't
want to do that because playgrounds are
a place to go out and get open air but
you have to exercise social density even
in a playground and again it's voluntary
the mayor is going to make it clear that
this is important to the people of the
city if it doesn't happen we will
actually close down the playgrounds I
don't want to do that but we do need to
reduce the spread of the infection and
that is what is most important this is
very interesting because the evidence
suggests that the density controlled
measures may be working and again we're
doing this from projections but look at
this because it's interesting this past
Sunday the projection was that
hospitalizations were doubling every two
days okay
on Monday the number suggested that the
hospitalizations were doubling every
three point four days on Tuesday the
projections suggested that the
hospitalizations were doubling every
four point seven days
now that is almost too good to be true
but the theory is given the density that
we're dealing with it spreads very
quickly but if you reduce the density
you can reduce the spread very quickly
so these projections I've watched them
bounce all over the place and I don't
place a great deal of stock in in any
one projection all due respect to all
the great academics and statisticians
who are doing it but this is a very good
sign and a positive sign again I I'm not
a hundred percent sure it holds or it's
accurate but the arrows are headed in
the right direction and that is always
better than the arrows headed in the
wrong direction so to these them people
say boy these are burdensome
requirements social distancing no
restaurants no non-essential workers yes
they are burdensome by the way they are
effective and they're necessary and the
evidence suggests at this point that
they have slowed the hospitalizations
and this is everything slowing the
hospitalization rates coming into the
hospitals are everything so the
hospitals can deal with the rate of
people coming in at the same time
increase hospital capacity what is the
high point you see that line in the
beginning what we're studying is what is
the high point of that line what is the
apex of that line that is the point of
the greatest number of people coming
into the hospital system so that's our
greatest load is the apex and when is
that going to happen again that is a
projection again that moves around but
the current projection is that could be
in 21 days so ramp up the hospital
capacity to make to be able to handle
that apex volume how do you ramp up
hospital capacity you ramp up bed
you ramp up staff and you wrap up the
equipment and the ventilators are the
problem in equipment as we've discussed
many times where are we on that beds
we may need 140,000 we have 53,000
that's the existing capacity of
hospitals we told all hospitals they
have to increase their capacity by 50% I
told them that myself on a conference
call yesterday this is a burden for the
hospitals to now say you have to
increase capacity fifty percent but I
have to tell you they were very generous
about it and they understood what we
were dealing with and they were eager to
step up to the plate if you increase
Hospital capacity by 50%
that gets you 27,000 beds on top of the
existing it takes you to 80 some
hospitals I asked as a goal try to
increase by 100 percent your capacity 50
percent was the minimum the goal was 100
I believe some hospitals will actually
try to do that and I encouraged them to
try to do that as impossible as it
sounds but now is the time to be
aggressive and do things you've never
done before if some of them do that and
I believe some of them will that would
be additional 5,000 beds we get to
85,000 beds
FEMA Army Corps of Engineers what we're
doing in Javits Center what we're doing
in the Westchester Convention Center
Westbury campus Stony Brook campus
that's another 4,000 takes us to
eighty-nine thousand the US Navy ship
comfort the president dispatched that
would be a thousand beds to backfill
from hotels that they should a 90
thousand if we take all the state
dormitories in downstate New York that
could get us an additional 29 thousand
beds we'd be at a hundred and nineteen
thousand beds you're still not at the
140 that you need but then we're looking
at hotels we'll look
at former nursing homes converting other
facilities to make up the differential
so a lot creative aggressive but in life
you do what you have to do and this is
that's what we're doing on the bed
capacity protective equipment we have
been shopping around the world we have a
whole team that's doing it right now we
have enough protective equipment gloves
masks gowns for all the hospitals
statewide that are dealing with it I put
down a ship into New York City yesterday
today no hospital no nurse no doctor can
say legitimately I don't have protective
equipment right now and for the
foreseeable future we have a supply we
do not yet have secure to supply for
three weeks from now four weeks from now
five weeks from now but we are still
shopping and taking care of this
immediate need was also good news and a
good job by the team and again we are
still shopping for more equipment
ventilators ventilators ventilators we
need 30,000 we have in the existing
hospital system 4,000 ventilators this
is just in the normal operation of
hospitals etc we have purchased 7,000
and we are still shopping federal
government has sent 4,000 we're
exploring splitting where one ventilator
could do to patients Italy has had to do
this because they were forced to do it I
want to see if we can study it and do it
a little smarter and have a little more
time experimenting with it but we're
looking at splitting the ventilators
we're still working with the federal
government to try to find more
ventilators but that is our single
greatest challenge are the ventilators
again the ICU beds that really means a
ventilated bed because again this is the
number one piece of equipment that we
need you have beds you have equipment
you need staff
and you need staff understanding that
some staff is going to get sick and
they're going to be out so we have been
working on putting together a surge
healthcare force go back to the retirees
go back to nurses and doctors who may
not be in the hospital direct medical
care occupation and ask them to sign up
for possible reserve duty god bless them
40,000 people have signed up as a surge
health care force
mm anesthesiologist emergency room
technicians nurse practitioners
physician assistants nurse anesthetist
respiratory RNs LPNs
40,000 people have signed up that is a
very big big deal because you can create
beds you can find the equipment you have
to have the staff and you have to have
the staff for those additional beds
which are not now in the hospital system
and you have to have staff when the
existing staff gets ill or by the way
just can't work the hours that we're
going to need people to be working so
that's very good this is also very
exciting I don't know that anyone else
has done this we've talked about the
emotional stress that this brings on
people and the mental health stress and
the mental health challenges no one's
really talking about this you know we're
all concerned about the immediate
critical need the life and the debt life
and death of the immediate situation
which is right but don't underestimate
the emotional trauma that people are
feeling and the emotional health issues
we asked for mental health professionals
to voluntarily sign up to provide online
mental health services 6,000 mental
health professionals agreed to volunteer
to provide men
Health Services for people who need it
how beautiful is that
and the hotline one eight four four
eight six three nine three one four you
can call that hotline you can schedule
an appointment with a mental health
professional totally free to talk to
them about what you're feeling and what
stress you're feeling and again god
bless the six thousand mental health
professionals who are doing this 100%
free on top of whatever they have to do
in their normal practice and I'm showing
their normal practice their busy so this
is really an extraordinary extraordinary
step by them federal government I spoke
with President Trump several times I
spoke with him last night I spoke with
him this morning I've spoken to people
in the White House who were handling
these operations I've spoken with the
vice president
I've spoken with Jared Kushner who is a
New Yorker he knows New York and he's
working in the White House and he's he's
been extraordinarily helpful on all of
these situations what would what we're
working on is a common challenge
no one has these ventilators and no one
ever anticipated a situation where you
would need this number of ventilators to
deal with the public health emergency so
we have purchased everything that can be
purchased we're now in a situation that
we're trying to accelerate production of
these ventilators and a ventilator is a
complicated piece of equipment the
president and his team I think are using
the DPA well because it's basically a
form
it's a leverage tool when you're dealing
with private companies right we need
your help we can demand your help or you
could agree to help and we need you to
step up and increase production even
with that there's a ramp up
time for a company to put together the
supply chain put together the workforce
and get these things up and running so
Ford you here is going to help General
Motors is going to help the problem is
our timeline is so short when looking at
an apex 21 days in that range to get
ventilators and these business
consortiums put together supply chain
design team ramped up and delivered a
30,000 ventilators is an extraordinarily
difficult task and it's something that
our team is working on with the White
House team and I want to thank the
president for his cooperation and his
team for their cooperation we're getting
very creative we're talking to countries
around the world as well as new
companies that could do production we're
also talking to the White House
about another concept New York has the
greatest need in terms of numbers New
York also has the most critical need in
terms of timing right we talked about
our apex we talked about that curve
different localities different regions
around the country are going to have
different curves we are in some ways
first our case numbers went up first our
trajectory is first by a long shot
different regions will have their curve
at different times what I said to the
president and his team was look rather
than saying we have to provide equipment
for the entire country at one time let's
talk about addressing the critical need
in that hot spot once that hot spot
turns because you have an apex and then
you have a curve and the curve is
relatively short once you address that
hot spot with that intensity and
equipment intense personnel then shift
to the next hot spot and have more of a
rolling deployment across the country
than a static deployment right I was in
the federal government at HUD I worked
on dozens of disasters you deal with the
disaster in front of you at that time
and then you move on to the next
disaster and I think that rolling
deployment could work here and on behalf
of New York I said we will be 100%
helpful we need help from the entire
country right now we need resources from
the entire country right now and because
our apex is first and our numbers are
highest
but the apex high point will be
sequential across the country so I said
to the White House send us the equipment
that we need send us the personnel as
soon as we get past our critical moment
we will redeploy that equipment and
personnel to the next hotspot and I will
personally guarantee it and personally
manage it so if you send us 15,000
ventilators and then after our curve Los
Angeles needs 15,000 ventilators we can
take the equipment from here we can take
the personnel from here we can take the
lessons from here you know we go first
we're going to learn things that nobody
else has learned because we're going to
be the first one through the chute and I
personally guarantee that we will bring
that equipment we will bring that
personnel we'll bring that technical
assistance to the next hotspot I said to
the president I'll be part of going to
the next hotspot with our team we're
asking the country to help us we will
return the favor and we are all in this
together
and we're asking for their help and
their consideration and we will repay it
with dividends the Senate is also
considering a two trillion dollar bill
which is quote unquote relief for
businesses individuals and governments
it would really be terrible for the
state of New York the two trillion
dollar bill what does it mean for New
York state government that means 3.8
billion dollars 3.8 million dollars
sounds like a lot of money
Rob mihika the budget director can talk
you through the numbers but we're
looking at a shortfall revenue shortfall
of nine ten fifteen billion dollars this
response to this virus has probably
already cost us one billion dollars it
will probably cost us several billion
dollars when we're done New York City
only gets one point three billion
dollars from this package that is a drop
in the bucket as to need I spoke to our
House delegation congressional
delegation this morning I said to them
just doesn't do it you know I understand
the Senate theory and the Republican
theory but we need the house to make
adjustments in the House bill that went
over New York State got 17 billion
dollars in this Senate bill we get 3.8
billion dollars and well you just see a
big spending we're not a big spending
state I cut taxes every year I have the
lowest growth rate of the state budget
in modern political history okay
so we are frugal and we are efficient
I'm telling you these numbers don't work
and I told the House members that we
really need their help in terms of
numbers total tested we're up to 130,000
people new tests were up to 12,000
as of yesterday about 28% of all testing
nationwide has been performed by the
state of New York state of New York is
doing more testing than any state in the
United States of America and are very
proud of the team on how we've mobilized
and gotten this testing up and running
people ask how does this testing work
any hospital in the state can perform
testing you can walk into a hospital in
Buffalo New York if you show the
symptoms and meet the protocol you can
be tested strategically we deploy
testing in the most dense areas where do
we set up the drive throughs etc why
because we're hunting positives we're
hunting positives so we can isolate them
and reduce the spread you're more likely
to get positives in a high positive
areas right set up a drive-through in
the Bronx versus set up a drive-through
in Chautauqua County you're going to get
more positives in the Bronx and that's
what we want
but anyone anywhere in the state you
have symptoms you're concerned you can
walk into any hospital that hospital can
get a test perform number of positive
cases where up to 30,000 number of new
cases five thousand again you see the
numbers 13,000
I'm sorry 17,000 New York City four
thousand and Westchester 3,000 in Nassau
County relatively Westchester we have
dramatically slowed what was an
exponential increase so again on the
good news side can you slow the rate of
infection yes how do you know look at
what we did in Westchester that was the
hottest cluster in the United States of
America we closed the schools we closed
gatherings
we brought in testing and we have
dramatically slowed the increase Nassau
County is 3,000
they're relatively right behind
Westchester they were at like zero when
Westchester had started so we can slow
it and we have slowed it again
you see it's spreading across the state
which we said it would current numbers
30,000 tested positive twelve percent of
those who test positive are hospitalized
three percent of the positives are in
ICU okay this is deep breath time again
I'm anxious I'm nervous what does it
mean
thirty thousand tested positive twelve
percent are in the hospital three
percent are in ICU if you look at those
three percent they're going to be
predominantly senior citizens people
with underlying illnesses people with
emphysema people with a compromised
immune system
that's what this effort is all about all
the noise all the energy it's about that
three percent take a deep breath now
that three percent that's my mother
that's your mother that's your sister
these are people we love these are our
grandparents and we're going to do
everything we can to protect every one
of them and I give the people of the
state of New York my word that we're
doing it but we're talking about three
percent of the people who talked
positive and tested positive who we're
worrying about most impacted states were
30,000 next closest state is New Jersey
at three California too
this is a really dramatic differential
and this is what I argue to anyone who
will listen we have ten times the
problem that the next state has which is
New Jersey you compares to California
which is larger in terms of population
we have 15 times the problem now you
have to ask yourself why why does New
York have such a high number and again
in the totality we understand what it
means but why does New York have such a
high number and this is my personal
opinion I'd like to make sure that I
separate facts from personal opinion the
facts I give you with the best facts I
have and again the data changes day to
day but I give you exactly what I have
on a day to day basis personal opinion
why does New York have so many more
cases than any other state how can it be
your 15 times the number of California I
mean it really is breathtaking when you
think about it state of Massachusetts
with 30 times the number of cases so why
is the question that people ask me to
answers answer one is because we welcome
people from across the globe we have
people coming here we have people who
came here from China who came here from
Italy who came here from countries all
around the globe we have international
travelers who were in China and who were
in Italy and who were in Korea and who
came here and I had no doubt that the
virus was here much earlier than we even
know and I have no doubt that the virus
was here much earlier than it was in any
other state because those people come
here first that's the first answer the
second answer is because we are close
because we are close we talk about the
the virus and how it transfers in a
dense area
it's literally because we are close
because we live
close to one another because we're close
to one another on the street because we
live in close communities because we're
close to one another on the bus we're
close to one another in the restaurant
we're close to one another in the movie
theater and we have one of the most
dense close environments in the country
and that's why the virus communicated
the way it did our closeness makes us
vulnerable our closeness makes us
vulnerable that spacial closeness makes
us vulnerable but it's true that your
greatest weakness is also your greatest
strength and our closeness is what makes
us who we are that is what New York is
our closeness is what makes us special
our acceptance our openness is what
makes us special it's what makes us feel
so connected one to another it's what
makes us so accepting of one another
it is the closeness that makes us the
human beings that we are the closeness
is that New York humanity that I think
exists nowhere else the closeness is
what makes our sense of community and
there's a gentleman who I still look to
for guidance and for leadership and for
inspiration he's not here anymore
for you he's still here for me but he
said things more profound and more
beautifully than most other people ever
have
and one of the things he said that is so
appropriate for today we believe in a
single fundamental idea that describes
better than most textbooks in any speech
that I could write what a proper
government should be the idea of family
mutuality the sharing of benefits and
burdens for the good of all feeling one
another's pain sharing one another's
blessings reasonably honestly fairly
without respect to race or sex or
geography or political affiliation that
is New York it is that closeness that
concept of family of community that's
what makes New York New York and that's
what made us vulnerable here but it is
also that closeness and that connection
and that humanity and that sharing that
is our greatest strength and that is
what is going to overcome at the end of
the day I promise you that I can see how
New Yorkers are responding I can see how
New Yorkers are treating one another
I see the 6,000 mental health volunteers
I see the 40,000 health care workers
stepping up I see the vendors calling me
saying I can help that's New York that's
New York and that my friends is
undefeatable and I am glad in some ways
that were we're first with this
situation because we will overcome and
we will show the other communities
across this country how to do it we'll
be there for them we want them to be
there for us and we will be there for
each other as we always have been any
questions
we have no anticipation of having to
prioritize ventilator usage our goal is
to have a ventilator for anyone who
needs one you should have numbers that
show 15,000 and you say you're gonna
need 40,000 so some some nitty-gritty
questions where are those ventilators
that have come in from FEMA going did
you get any commitment from the White
House that they're gonna send more than
the 4,000 that they've committed already
and what is the plan to reach that
number the same way you were planning to
increase hospital beds yeah it's a good
question Jimmy first the ventilators
that are coming in we're putting in the
stockpiled we'll deploy from the
stockpile as we need them literally
deploy on a need basis right so if one
Hospital calls up and says we're
overwhelmed this is what we need we'll
be in a position to deploy the increase
the beds is within our control right
there are beds in this state they're not
hospital beds and you have to figure out
how to convert them to hospital beds and
you have to figure out how to get access
to them but we have beds so that is a
logistical operational challenge how do
you don't turn the dorm room into a
hospital bed right how do we build a
hospital in Javad center the ventilators
are different we don't have them the
federal government does not have them
either no one has a stock pile of these
the federal government has to acquire
them the same way we have to acquire
them I'm working with the White House in
creative ways to acquire getting
companies to ramp up getting companies
to retrofit other machines this rolling
deployment methodology but nobody has
them there is no medical stockpile in
Washington
magically can make them appear 2015
where the state suggested or a task
force suggested maybe New York should
increase in stockpile Jimmy that's not
the fact that you know read the fact
checkers on it there was an advisory
commission called law and the life life
in the law that had a chart in 2015 that
said if you had the 1918 Spanish flu
pandemic you may need X number of
ventilators there was no state in the
United States that bought ventilators
for the 1918 Spanish flu endemic the
federal government did not buy
ventilators for the 1918 Spanish flu
pandemic nobody in the world
bought ventilators in preparation for a
1918 Spanish flu pandemic yes short
answer is yes do you know dr. Zucker the
number of people who've resolved does
anyone have that here
besides the Hopkins number we have
hundreds and hundreds of people who have
left the hospital and those are
individuals have resolved and there are
many other individuals who never even
came into the hospital we can try to get
you an exact number on that well well we
were following the CDC guidelines and
recommendations that after seven days if
you were positive and after seven days
of being positive and as long as you are
set more than 72 hours without symptoms
then you can go back to to where this is
the best data ok this is Johns Hopkins
it's every case since China four hundred
thirty five thousand nineteen thousand
deaths and again I'll bet you dollars to
doughnuts you look at those 19 thousand
senior citizen compromised immune system
emphysema etc recoveries a hundred
thousand right roughly 25 percent
pending three hundred thousand but yes
the recoveries are recoveries you get it
people we've had people I know they say
home for two weeks and they've done test
negative you can test negative in two
weeks you can test negative in three
weeks you can test negative in one week
after you have it that is going to be
the vast overwhelming number of people
the biggest number when this is done and
we can actually go back and test the
biggest number is going to be people who
had it who resolved who never knew they
had that's going to be the biggest
number and the reason we want to get to
that test is because then when you talk
about restarting the economy you have a
test that says you Andrew we're exposed
to it in February and by the way you are
recovered and you have the antibodies go
back to work
I'm sorry miss I cut off Jessie and when
I cut off Jessie then he gets annoyed at
me and then I so it's 3,000 the ICU beds
for our purposes our beds with
ventilators okay that's really we can
create today more ICU beds with
ventilators we already have in-house
right so we have 14,000 ventilators if
we had two today we could create 14,000
ventilated beds if we were bumping up
against capacity that right that's
correct I think the term ICU bed in this
world that we're living in right now
is different and so a recovery room
where the ventilator is an ICU bed and
so I think that just fixing on the exact
numbers but we have asked all the
hospitals for that information for about
1.2 million additional healthcare
workers to come to New York State that's
going on a rolling basis so you'll see
many of these numbers which the governor
presented today increase exponentially
as those calls are going out it's not
just in state we've also asked for
out-of-state retirees that we've had
health care workers volunteer from
Connecticut New Jersey and other parts
of the country as well and now we're
ranging for them to come to this area as
needed there was respiratory therapists
in there who have volunteered as well
we've seen reports from the from federal
federal sources saying that basically
New York's it will run
of ICU beds by Friday are you seeing
similar reports and are you reacting to
those no I didn't see those reports I'm
reacting to the numbers that we have and
you just saw the numbers the current
number of ICU beds with ventilators
that's one number if you bring Jessie
our the ventilators we have in hand and
add those two beds that number goes up
14,000 we can move them on you know
multiple stockpiles which we did when we
ramped up the whole disaster emergency
management system so we are multiple
stockpiles we have these placed in
multiple stockpiles where you have to go
to the city there's a shorter trip you
have to go to we have a stockpile on
Long Island stockpile of the mid-hudson
Valley stockpile and Albany stockpiling
on my basement just in case the
stockpile runs out we had the ICU we
have the ventilators in the stockpiles
we have not brought them from the
stockpile to a hospital because we don't
have a hospital who was called up and
said I need a ventilated bed the workers
they are not yet being deployed unless
mr. Malhotra's if I'm incorrect he can
correct me which he enjoys doing the I
don't believe they're being deployed yet
they are reserved in case
well first they reserve for two purposes
you open new beds you now need staff for
the new beds we open up a dormitory 200
beds you don't have now you need staff
to do the 200 beds or you have a
hospital that has a severe shortage of
workers because of hours or sickness we
would backfill but Jim I don't I don't
believe we're now the
the reserves that's correct we're
looking at those issues as well there
there are some concerns have been raised
but we we as we mentioned and previous
press conference the governor said that
we should look at our rules and
regulations and adapt accordingly so
we're going to do that as well I was on
the phone with all the hospital
administrators the Department of Health
and say this in a nice way to work
Department of Health has multiple
regulations
to run the best health system in the
United States of America
and those regulations make it so the
regulations can sometimes get in the way
of expedition and facilitation and
mobilization so we said in this case
we're going to relax many of the
regulations so they can staff up they
can increase capacity you know you ask
the hospital to double capacity we have
also some space regulations you have to
be so you need flexibility for them to
do what we're asking them to do
if I need to work within New York City
but Rikers is run by New York City you
may have a point
no I was just gonna say New York City is
already doing that on their own so it's
not something that they need us on but
we talk to New York City seventy seven
times a day so if that conversation
needs to be had it'll be had 78 no I
can't you need to be a Congress person
you need to be a senator I've
communicated with all of them
I understand the Washington bureaucracy
I was there but I passed bills when I
was HUD secretary I know how hard it is
but I also know how high the stakes are
here you look at the loss in the revenue
what you guys have been talking about to
me how do you do a state budget with
that dramatic loss in revenue and Rob
mihika has been saying well the federal
government is going to pass a stimulus
package that delivers additional funding
to state governments okay here's the
package it gives us 3.8 billion dollars
the hole is as big as as high as fifteen
billion dollars how do you plug a
fifteen billion dollar hole with 3.8
billion you don't by the president look
I believe I think it's part it's part
language right nobody will say it is
sustainable to clothe keep the economy
closed it's not sustainable we all get
that China got it South Korea got it etc
that's point one point two everyone
agrees I believe in this state we do
everything we can
to save a life we are not going to
triage and say well these were old
people these were vulnerable people they
had to die sometime soon anyway so let's
move on I don't believe any American
believes that I know New Yorkers don't
believe that and as governor of the
state of New York I can swear to you I
would never do that so then you have to
two parallel thoughts you have to get
the economy running and you have to
protect every life that you can I
believe there's a more refined strategy
than we are now talking about I don't
think it's binary I don't think you
close down the whole economy which is
what we did I did too and then open up
the whole society to business as usual
we now have learned that there's a risk
stratification quotient younger people
have less risk people who have the virus
in a result have less risk start that
economy by bringing in those recovered
people those younger people who are less
at risk and start moving that machine
that way start restarting the economy
that way which is also the best public
health strategy right to the extent you
have a young person who's going out to
the park not playing basketball because
they're not allowed to do that but
they're going out there talking to
friends etc they're then coming back
into the house with an older person that
is not a good public health strategy so
there is a path that refines the public
health strategy and starts growing the
economy and I think that's what we have
to that's what we have to work through
you could both the feds roll back the
restrictions does that affect you I mean
do you automatically back do you keep in
place according to your own speed the
federal government has done guidelines
they call them guidelines because they
are guidelines and then states can
follow the guidelines states can fashion
the guidelines to fit their specific
circumstance there is no doubt that New
York has a different and bigger problem
than anywhere else in the country right
that's every number you see that's every
fact you know so there's no doubt what
we have a greater challenge here in New
York density numbers and one of the most
intense economies so that all has to be
taken into consideration and I don't
think there is any cookie cutter you
know what works for New York I don't
know necessarily is gonna work for Tulsa
or San Antonio so we'll come up with a
plan that works for New York and the
federal government isn't saying we
mandate anything they're saying we're
offering guidelines New York City should
self-quarantine for two weeks and second
question we'll use self quarantine since
you were in New York City yesterday self
quarantine in New York State New York
South quarantine for two weeks in New
York no I don't think if you were in New
York City you must quarantine in New
York State you don't have to go back to
New York City to quarantine I'm going to
quarantine in New York State that is a
that is a medical advisory most
important thing in life is to know what
you don't know I don't know medicine I
would turn to the doctor so I think you
need to follow the CDC guidelines and
the CDC guidelines recommend that you
stay a distance away social distancing
as well whether it's in New York or not
and
this is beyond New York as the
governor's mentioned is not just in New
York at these cases I would I would not
follow that I believe that you should
follow the guidelines in general they
should social distance and if you were
in New York you go somewhere else these
cases are all over this all over the
country it's not just New York we are at
the forefront as the governor has said
but it's elsewhere last question because
you're so polite and you wait if we
don't get more funding from the feds I
don't know how we write the budget and
that's why this Senate bill is so
troublesome
I know the the politics of play nice and
don't say any who don't put any pressure
on any other elected official otherwise
they'll say you have sharp elbows and
you don't play nice in the sandbox this
is not a time to play nice in the
sandbox I represent the people of the
state of New York I get paid to
represent them I'm an attorney I'm an
advocate I'm a New Yorker born and bred
I'm New York tough if you are hurting
the people of the state I'm gonna do
everything I can do to defend them and
I'm gonna fight for the people of New
York to the best of my ability and we
need more federal help than this bill
gives us the House bill would have given
a 17 billion dollars this Senate bill
gives us three billion dollars I mean
that's a dramatic dramatic difference
I'm gonna go to work thank you very much
guys
not that this wasn't worth just like a
pleasure